Since this kind of construct is really quite common. Python provides a better
way to do it, and that's called with. A with statement looks like this. We've
got a ContextGuard which is some expression that evaluates an object. And we've
got some variable name. And I'm not going to go into all the details of how with
works. There is more details on this following the links below. But, as a useful
idiom for working with files, what we're going to do is use as our ContextGuard,
we're going to open the file, this is kind of like doing an assignment. The
value that the name fout refers to will be the result of this object, but the
big difference is the with statement guarantees that this magic method for
exiting will be called on this object, on the object returned by the
ContextGuard. And it guarantees that as long as this executes and we enter the
Block that exit will always be called. For a file, what exit does is cleans up
the file including calling file close. That means we don't need to explicitly
close the file at all. All we need to do is use with. So our code will look like
this. We'll use with open, opening the file, and assigning it to the variable
fout. We're going to do a bunch of stuff with it. We'll write to the file and
then after the with statement we can continue. And we know that this file will
always be closed. We don't need to explicitly call close.